un des secteurs très touchés par la
pandémie c'est celui du boeuf dans
l'ouest canadien
ces bêtes là sont nourris pendant près
de deux ans avant d'être envoyé à
l'abattoir et chaque journée
supplémentaire au parc d'engraissement
entraîne des coûts pour les éleveurs les
familles qui vivent de la production
bovine se remettent d'ailleurs d'un été
difficile
[Musique]
on
le sud ouest du manitoba où les grandes
cultures des prairies c'est souvent leur
place au pâturage des terrains
accidentés
parsemez de plans d'eau propice à
l'élevage du bétail
[Musique]
c'est ici que tu as et de raouf élèves
dévoue depuis une dizaine d'années à
leurs vaches maigres bas au printemps
les veaux sont nourris pendant quelques
mois puis vendu un parc d'engraissement
où ils prennent du poids avant d'être
livré à l'abattoir leurs troupeaux de
quelques centaines de vaches grandit peu
un peu chaque année
[Musique]
mais en 2019 il entame une expansion
majeure
il achète le troupeau du père de taylor
nous avons maintenant 600 vaches c'est
de loin le plus gros investissement que
nous avons fait à ce moment ils sont
loin de se douter que l'industrie bovine
est sur le point de vivre une crise sans
précédent hiver 2020 la pandémie éclate
l'économie de la planète est ébranlée
tous les secteurs d'activité sont
touchés comme le canada exporte 45% de
son boeuf les producteurs comme tyler
fothen craignent la dégringolade des
prix
[Musique]
l'industrie dépend beaucoup des
exportations et j'ai réalisé peu à peu
que l'impact sur nos opérations
pourraient être majeurs au printemps tél
à 200g nes à vendre et comme il l'avait
pressenti le prix du boeuf est en chute
libre et le revenu de nos ventes de vo
printemps représente environ 85% de
notre revenu annuel
donc nous avons une seule occasion qu'il
ne faut pas rater trouvera enfin à les
vendre en avril mais il encaisse une
perte de 20%
[Musique]
et le pire reste à venir de granby
france à s'échapper ambiance créée à la
fin avril
l'abattoir de corps gras en alberta est
aux prises avec la coved 19 950 cas
positifs sont dénombrés justine 16
complètement ses opérations pendant deux
semaines
pendant ce temps à 200 km à l'est
l'abattoir de djebahia brooks connaît
aussi une éclosion de la maladie 650
employés sont atteints de la coved 19
lusine réduit ses opérations de 60%
l'impact est majeur
à eux seuls ces deux abattoirs
transforme près des trois quarts du
boeuf produite au canada soit plus de
huit mille bêtes par jour
eric schmidt un éleveur de bovins à bord
est en alberta est parmi les premiers à
en subir les contrecoups dans son parc
d'engraissement 12000 bovins sont sur le
point d'être livré à l'abattoir mais à
la fin avril
impossible de faire abattre ses bêtes du
coup c'est revenu tombe alors que ses
dépenses pour maintenir ces animaux en
vie ne cesse d'augmenter
il y un engorgement dans les parcs
d'engraissement alors des bovins il faut
les garder 60 ou 70 jours de plus pour
nous ça peut représenter 200 à 300
dollars de plus en mouly pour chaque
animal c'est vraiment beaucoup d'argent
à la fin mai cent trente mille bêtes
sont entassés dans les parcs
d'engraissement
[Musique]
toute la chaîne de production bovine en
et affective
chez les fontaines on craint de subir
une autre perte importante
cette fois avec les animaux qui viennent
de naître
alors on pensé ok mais la prochaine fois
qu'on doit vendre nos animaux peut-être
ça sera mieux mais ça peut durer une
autre offre
je ne me souviens pas pour avec une
situation plus stressante que ça sur la
ferme aux prête en 2020
il devient de plus en plus évident que
l'industrie bovine dépend entièrement de
quelques gros abattoir selon david
thorne professeur en économie de la
santé animale à l'université de calgary
la pandémie a mis au jour la
vulnérabilité de la chaîne de production
bovine au pays
nous n'avons pas de zone tampon pour
éviter la congestion dans les parcs
d'engraissement et chaque jour qui passe
quant au moins 1 $ de plus par tête
en juin les abattoirs en alberta
reprennent enfin leur cadence normale de
production
les mesures de distanciation physique
ayant été mises en place pour protéger
les employés
mais il faudra des mois avant que les
dizaines de milliers de bêtes qui
attendent dans les parcs d'engraissement
ne soit abattu
[Musique]
au coeur de cet été sombre une lueur
d'espoir les récoltes de foin et de maïs
est excellent chez les footeux ça fait
toute la différence
je suis confiant maintenant qu'on
passera à travers la tempête avec une
mauvaise récolte j'aurais peut-être été
forcés de vendre mes bêtes à un moment
où les prix sont au plus bas
nous avons plus de flexibilité
au début juillet greg schmitt réussit
enfin à vendre ses bêtes
le roulement dans son parc
d'engraissement revient plus ou moins à
la normale
les abattoirs cargo et gb s ajoutent à
la fin de l'été des quarts de travail la
fin de semaine pour répondre à la
demande
[Musique]
on abat 5 à 10% plus de bêtes qu'à la
normale
[Musique]
la demande est là
s'il n'y avait pas de débouchés pour les
produits du boeuf on ne ferait pas tant
de transformation c'est un très bon
signe pour l'industrie bovine
malgré la demande le prix du boeuf à la
fin de l'été est environ 10% inférieur à
l'an dernier
on reçoit environ 10 dollars de moins
par son livre par rapport aux prix
habituels à ce temps ci de l'année pour
un animal de 1500 livres par exemple ça
représente 150 dollars
selon dave et ford
il faut repenser toute la chaîne de
production bovine facilité par exemple
la mise sur pied de petits abattoirs
spécialisé dans les coupes sur mesure
qui pourrait être sollicitée en temps de
crise les petits abattoirs pourrait
prendre la relève car les grandes usines
sont obligés de fermer
d'ailleurs les bouchers le coup nous
disent qu'ils ont fait une excellente
été augmenté le nombre de petits
abattoirs nous donnerait du jeu et
améliorer l'efficacité de tout le
système est fait
[Musique]
c'était une bonne et et je me sens mieux
maintenant que je me sentais au
printemps
en septembre les fontaines ont repris
espoir
suite à la réouverture des grands
abattoirs
[Musique]
on est aujourd'hui dans une bien
meilleure position qu'on aurait pu le
croire
il se demande tout de même si la
pandémie ne changera pas à long terme
les habitudes des consommateurs les
sticks de qualité vendus dans les
restaurants rapporte énormément à
l'industrie bovine mais là on ne sait
pas si les clients seront encore au
rendez vous
persuadé que les prix rebondiront il
songe à agrandir de nouveau leur ferme
une conséquence inattendue de la
pandémie
[Musique]
la pandémie a poussé quelques fermiers
du coin à prendre une retraite anticipée
nous comptons louées 200 hectares de
plus l'an prochain et peut être acheté
un nouveau terrain j'espère seulement
que l'industrie bovine pourra se
remettre de la crise
[Musique]
l'engouement pour l'achat local suscité
par la pandémie a été porteur de bonnes
nouvelles pour les éleveurs de boeuf du
québec
les abattoirs québécois de plus petite
taille se sont rapidement adaptés pour
répondre à la demande
résultat jusqu'ici cette année on a
transformé trois fois plus de viande
bovine dans la province qu'à pareille
date l'an dernier